This video is sponsored by Audible
Which means I put a link down at the top of my description to
click that link and by starting a 30-day free trial you'll get your first audiobook for free
Welcome back. My name is Nate, and I want to thank you for joining me today on the king of random today
We're going to show you how to take a project that we've done before and ramp it up to the next level
In a previous video we showed you how to make a matchbook rocket-launching kit
So now we're gonna take what you learned in that video and step it up to the next level
Using simple parts to build a revolver that can shoot six rockets in a row now the previous video showing how to make an entire
Rocket launch pad was actually the first video
I ever saw on the king of random
So I'm really excited to show you how to take these little rockets and turn it into something bigger
There's two parts to this build and the first part is making the rocket themselves to make the rockets we need aluminum foil
Aluminum tape a box of matches and a couple of bamboo skewers the second part of the build is the revolver itself and for that
all you're going to need is some cardboard from a cereal box of your choice some more bamboo skewers a
barbecue lighter and some small zip ties
the previous matchbox Rockets video explains in a lot of detail how to make these little Rockets
But we're just going to go over the process really quick for you right now
using the provided
Pattern cut the five sided shape out of aluminum foil the previous video shows how you can use paper towel or toilet paper to cut
Out several of these shapes at once which is what we're going to want to do since we have several rockets to launch
If you don't include the layers of toilet paper or a paper towel between the foil the edges will curl together
And you won't be able to separate your different pieces of foil
The provided pattern shows how far the bamboo skewers should be rolled into the foil rocket
Update guys, we have a bunch of our foil Rockets made
And we're ready to start building the revolver to launch them off the first thing you need to do is cut a flat piece of
cardboard out of your cereal box
The next step is to figure out
what size of circle to cut out of the cardboard for our revolver on my barbecue lighter you can see that the flame is a
little under 1 inch high after measuring your flame measure that same distance from either side of your barbecue lighter this measurement will give you
a good estimate for the spacing of your six rocket revolver launch rods
We're going to want to trace out two sizes of circles the first is the size of the measurement you just took and the other
one should be
1/4 to 3/8 of an inch larger in diameter the best way to do that is with a compass if you don't have a compass
There are several household items
You can use to trace like a cup a roll of tape or the lid to a spray can
You'll want to take the diameter of the measurement and draw two circles that size now
We'll extend our compass by about an eighth of an inch and draw a second circle around each of our first circles now
We'll show you a trick to get six equally spaced points around your circle so that your rocket-launch rods will be equally spaced
Using the measurement of the radius of your first circle place the point of the compass on the edge of the circle
Mark where your pencil touches the line of your drawn circle as well as the point where your compass was
Using a drill bit the same size of your barbecue lighter you want to drill a hole in the center of each of your cardboard
Circles with my barbecue lighter. I'm using a 3/8 inch bit
Next using a drill bit the same size as your bamboo skewers drill out each of the six points around a circle
I find that a 1/8 inch fit is just the right size
If the edges of the holes are a little bit ragged once you've drilled them just go over them with a little bit of sandpaper
Once you've got all of your holes drilled you're ready to cut out your circles
Next find six bamboo skewers that are pretty straight at least on the top half turn all of the bamboo skewers about halfway down the
Tapered point and then lightly sand the top two inches
We've got all of our parts ready and it's time to start assembling
But you know that here at the king of random we like to decorate and now is the time to do that
OK, we've decorated all of our pieces now
Let's put it all together start pushing your bamboo skewers through the holes that you drilled in both pieces of cardboard
Try to be sure that the tips of the bamboo all reach the same length in front of the cardboard and that the two pieces
Of cardboard are parallel to each other
Before we permanently attach the skewers to the cardboard we want to make sure the whole mechanism is properly aligned
To make sure that the extra bits of the bamboo skewer aren't hitting the handle of your lighter while you're doing the alignment clip everything
Off about a quarter inch behind the back piece of cardboard
Once you have all of your bamboo skewers inserted and properly aligned secure them in place with a few drops of superglue
Once the glue has dried your rocker revolver is almost finished, and there's just a couple more details
We need to add you want to move your revolver
Apparatus to where the points of the bamboo skewers lines up with the tip of the flame
Attach a zip tie to the barbecue lighter tighten it most of the way and move it forward until it is pressing against the cardboard
circle
Attach a second zip tie right behind it facing the other direction screw the revolver apparatus up to the front of the barbecue lighter
So you can really cinch the zip ties as tight as they will go add one more zip tie to the front of the barbecue
Lighter press it up against the cardboard and cinch it tight
Clip the front zip tie as close to the locking mechanism as you can get
on the back zip ties you'll want to cut one of them about one millimeter above the level of the bamboo skewer and one of
them halfway down the bamboo skewer a
Couple drops of superglue will secure the two zip ties together and permanently attach them to the barbecue lighter
the to cut zip ties work as a locking mechanism
To keep your revolver in place as you switch from one shot to the next and now your rocket revolver is complete and ready to
Use let's load up those Rockets. We made before and fire them off now while Nate's getting that set up
Let's take a second to talk about audible so audible is an app that I have on my phone
It's one that I use all the time professional narrators read books
You can just basically plug in your headphones and listen to audio books wherever you go now
I know a lot of you go to work. You're taking the car
You're getting stuck in rush-hour traffic, or you're waiting for the train
What are you doing with that downtime audible is a service that hires professional narrators to read books that you can download
Plug in your headphones and listen to at the bus stop or on your daily commute so instead of wasting time now
You're improving your time jump down to description click the link for audible.com slash
The king of random and sign up for a 30-day free trial that'll allow you to download an audiobook like this one
I'm reading called The E-Myth by Michael Gerber, which I highly recommend you ever wonder
Why so many businesses fail or so many youtubers experience creator burnout?
This book really opened my eyes, and told me why as I was reading this book
I related to it like that is me
But it really is a great service guys one of my favorite features is you can listen to the stories on two times or three
Times speed so you can actually cram information as fast as you can process it in your brain
I really like that feature a lot. I use it my wife uses it and pretty much everyone
I know
uses audible so if you're not on audible yet jump down to the description click the link for audible.com slash the king of random and
Join the club the book club has there were alright. Let's jump back and see what Nate's doing
Alright guys and here it is all put together the rocket revolver
We've got six rockets loaded onto the front we can rotate from one to the next and launch them off one after another
Let's test out with this bad boy can do
There you have it guys
That's how to take the matchbox rockets from a previous video and amp it up to the next level so you have your very own
Rocket revolver using this revolver you can shoot off six rockets in a row which is a lot more firepower
This is a fun build that you can do in not very much time that takes rocketry to a much more mobile
Level check the link in the description below for the template for these rockets and start launching
Thanks for joining me in this project and I look forward to the next one talk to you then
This is audible
Hey guys
Just a quick reminder to drop down to the description click the link for audible.com slash
The king of random really is a great service. I use it my wife uses it my brother-in-law uses it pretty much everyone
I know uses it, and I think you'll like it too too much tape
I'm very fast draw. I have very slow boards